a Porsche with a hybrid system and the
Porsche with four seats the Panamera has
already dished out its share of
surprises for sports car fans now for
the second generation the Panamera for
plug-in hybrid has been joined by
another with 500 kilowatts of system
power but for today well stick with the
less powerful plug-in hybrid it's
electric motor and 243 kilowatt v6
gasoline engine add up to a total system
power of 340 kilowatts fuel consumption
is rated at just 2.5 liters per 100
kilometers but only as long as the
driver resists the temptation to really
step on it artistic I know Dyson /
points out that since the Panamera a
hybrid weighs two point two tons it
takes some power to push that weight
from zero to 100 km/h in just five
seconds but the system has a good 700
Newton meters of torque the normal drive
mode recharges the battery on the go and
then there are the Sport and Sport Plus
modes and all three the overboost
function temporarily steps up the boost
pressure for the pickup typical of
Porsche Yugo story out in Morales son
doesn't stupid Pasha as in most hybrids
the display can show the energy flow at
any time
a Porsche is a Porsche is a Porsche the
design has spoken the same easily
recognizable language for decades and
the Panamera is no exception
the e hybrid differs from the four
cedars gasoline powered version only in
small details such as the green rim
badging and the green brake calipers the
Panamera for a hybrid is 5 meters and 5
centimetres long
the longer executive body style is
available on request
[Music]
tucked under the front hood is the v6
with 2.9 liters capacity
[Music]
Byron Paul Stine Holt realizes that with
a Porsche sound is always a factor an
all-electric drive the e hybrid glides
over the asphalt on its air suspension
in almost total silence but if you
really bring out the performance it
sounds just like the Porsches we've
always known
[Music]
the Panamera a hybrid pounces from 80 to
120 km/h in just 3.1 seconds only a
fraction of a second slower than other
Panamera variants because of the few
hundred extra kilos the battery adds
[Music]
and I know mines finaled explains that
it takes about six hours to fully
recharge the e hybrids battery from a
European 220 volt household outlet a
quick charge station for an extra four
and a half thousand euros will cut two
hours off that time the Panamera hybrids
competitors are the mercedes-benz S 500
and the BMW 7 Series in plug-in hybrids
but in the family of Panamera's a
Porsche II Hybrid is actually the lowest
priced of them all out so golfin